this week the case against the five men
accused of aiding the hijackers inch
forward with pre-trial hearings senior
investigative correspondent catherine
herridge was at ground zero on 9 11 and
has followed the case to the military
court in guantanamo bay cuba where she
joins us now catherine good morning
michelle this week lawyers argued over
the evidence and there is still no date
on the calendar for the actual trial to
begin
the five defendants including the
self-described architect of the attack
khalid sheikh mohammed are accused of
war crimes including conspiracy to
commit acts of terrorism hijacking and
the intentional murder of civilians
inside the high security court their
first appearance since the pandemic hit
the men appeared older some thinner
khalid sheikh mohammed stroked his long
white beard tinted orange on the sides
in the gallery a handful of 9 11 family
members it was a very emotional
experience for me it was
very moving very difficult
the biggest legal block is the men's cia
detention before they arrived at
guantanamo military prosecutors say they
are committed to a fair and just process
however long it takes dana catherine
herridge and guantanamo bay cuba thank
you catherine